today we're going to talk about space
walk so back in the old days property
owners had the rights to their land
going up forever and ever
in perpetuity but then the airplane came
around and smart people realized it you
couldn't just go around asking every
property owner for permission to fly
through their airspace so government
societ they would own the air above a
certain level in general government
decided that property owners owned their
land up to 500 feet above ground level
and then the air above that going up
infinitely was to be owned and
controlled by the government
this made life easier for airplanes but
then America invented space and that
made things a little more complicated in
most cases satellites and spacecraft
orbit around the earth so it would be a
logistical nightmare to request
permission to enter into the airspace of
each nation in an orbit once again smart
people got together and decided that
those air rights that countries had
given themselves should end at a certain
level different countries say different
things but all of them agree that
somewhere between 19 miles above earth
the altitude of the highest airplanes
and balloons and 99 miles above earth
the altitude of the lowest orbiting
satellites a country's claim to
sovereignty stops so this begs the
question which laws apply in space so
let's say an astronaut commits a small
crime all in space like I don't know
doing a line want a spacecraft this
isn't a huge crime against humanity but
they're gonna have to be punished if the
astronaut had those happy times on the
spacecraft of a specific country it
would be clear which country would
prosecute if it wasn't a Soyuz capsule
Russia would prosecute if it was in a
SpaceX capsule the US would prosecute
much like with boats the spacecraft is
considered to be an extension of the
sovereignty of that country but let's
say mr. astronaut did his line while on
the moon who would prosecute then the
Outer Space Treaty of 1967 says that no
country can claim a section of space or
a celestial body as their territory so
this means that no country's laws apply
universally on the moon well this is
where the idea of extraterritorial
jurisdiction comes into play in almost
every kind
citizens are subject to the laws of
their own country even if they are
outside of the country this doesn't
apply when they are in other countries
and see other countries laws Trump the
extraterritorial jurisdiction but when
they aren't in any country these laws do
apply this means that two people in the
exact same place can be subject to
different laws an 18 year old british
astronaut could technically drink on the
moon one 18 year old american astronaut
could not just to make things a little
bit more complicated the rules are
different on the International Space
Station this Space Station agreement the
document that outlines the rules of the
ISS says that in most cases
extraterritorial jurisdiction applies
each astronaut is subject to the laws of
their own country however if for example
an American astronaut say punches a
french one out of frustration France
will be allowed to prosecute American
astronaut the same rule applies with
property if a British astronaut smashes
a Canadian astronauts computer Canada
could prosecute the Brit in addition
this agreement allows for the
extradition of astronauts in all cases
regardless if the two countries have a
normal extradition treaty this is
actually pretty important because Russia
doesn't have an extradition treaty with
the US this means that Russia doesn't
have to give up individuals who have
committed a crime in which the US has
the right to prosecute in the case that
a Russian commits a crime against an
American on the ISS however Russia would
be obliged to extradite that astronaut
another situation and look at is what
would happen if a baby was born in space
first off this is a super hypothetical
because it's unknown if it's even
possible for a baby to be born in
zero-gravity and if they were their
bones would be so brittle that they
would crush under their own weight if
they return to gravity it's unlikely
that any country would allow for an
astronaut to have a baby in space
because that would be like super
unethical but for the sake of argument
let's say there was a space baby
what nationality would that baby be
there is actually precedent for this
question thirteen babies have been born
in Antarctica where there's a similar
treaty that disallows sovereignty
while those babies were not born in
their parents countries they took their
parents nationalities the same policy
applies in space there are countries
however that don't give citizenship to
babies born outside of the country so in
that case the baby would take the
citizenship of the country of the
spacecraft they were born in this is the
same rule that applies when a baby is
born on an airplane in flight they take
the nationality of their parents and if
that's not possible
they take the nationality of the country
in which the aircraft is registered and
what happens that the baby is born on
the Moon or Mars where there is no
sovereignty well I don't know man what
do I look like a lawyer but seriously
nobody really knows this is just one of
many flaws in current space law only 536
people have been to space and all of
them were highly trained and were
representing their country they just
aren't the type of people to commit
crimes as commercial spaceflight and
space tourism develop all these laws
will need to be made more clear to
prevent future problems gone is the era
when these laws can just be figured out
when and if the time comes in the near
future we could be seeing space mining
as well and that will require economic
laws and environmental treaties the
coming decades will be a fascinating
time as we watch not only the
development of commercial space
industries but also as we lay out the
legal and political groundwork needed
for the opening of the final frontier
following the bombing of Pan Am flight
103 over Scotland a deal with reach
between Gaddafi of Libya and the British
government in which the trial of the
accused bombers would happen in a
neutral country in return the
extradition